first they looked at the patina a thin
surface layer that forms overtime on the
outside of a rock or stone
as we see in this sample we have a very
thin well layer that about one
millimeter thick discovers the sample
the formation of a patina is caused by
the interaction of chemicals in air
water or soil with minerals in the stone
itself in this one we see very easy
Brown and we can see that it may be
thicker or thinner but it covers all
around and goes all around the sample
a patina developed slowly and may take
thousands of years to form the
geologists studying the stone found that
the patina was continuous across the
front of the stone and crucially within
the inscribed letters
they concluded the inscription must have
been carved in the distant past
next the geologists analyzed the
chemical makeup of the patina they were
looking for calcium carbonate and other
chemicals which would tell them if it
had formed in the Jerusalem area they
found that the trace elements like
strontium iron magnesium and other
elements that are in the calcium
carbonate they said exactly the same
propulsions as in the patina in a Joe
Samaria
the patina tests indicated that the
stone came from Jerusalem and that the
inscription really was very old the big
question now was how old
although it was impossible to date the
stone itself remarkably within the
patina
there were minut particles of charcoal
and these could be carbon-dated the
results were conclusive
they were 2,300 years old so the carving
beneath the patina had to be even older
there seemed to be no doubt that the
stone came from the Jerusalem area and
the inscription was thousands of years
old
and there was one last discovery that
reinforced the conclusion that it came
from the temple of Solomon the patina
contained tiny flecks of gold just what
one might expect from a stone that had
been through a fire in a temple lined
with gold